when they gave the farms away in
Zimbabwe it happened everybody's starved
you know why because no one knew how to
farm exactly and in in in China and in
Russia they did they said these people
who owned the farms are the bourgeoisie
they weren't know they call them
something else I can't member what it
was they were like the wealthy the
wealthy peasants so they got rid of them
and then gave the farms to the to the
actual farmers and guess what our to the
workers mm-hmm
the workers did not a farm same thing
everybody starved right so it's it's
well that's another thing we don't do
anymore as humans like you know back in
the day if your dad was a blacksmith you
were a blacksmith your son was a
blacksmith your grandsons a blacksmith
and so your name was Smith exactly right
so or you could be like John's we don't
do that anymore we were we were raised I
remember being a kid like you could do
anything you want I was like I want to
be out in the airforce and they're like
you're color blind you can't yeah and I
was like but I want to be an astronaut I
want to fly in space they're like sorry
no and that was just like Bob all right
no there goes that maybe in that most
people are taught you can do anything
you want and people believe it they're
like I can do anything I want I can't I
don't want to work for it
but I can do whatever I want maybe it's
like you got to work for it
so here's what you do hmm when you were
told that you couldn't be an astronaut
okay then you go to school for a biology
to find a cure for colorblindness
something that you could a treatment
that would repair that so my understand
of color blindness is like the cones are
pressing against each other okay so it
makes it hard to differentiate so like
humans are trichromats
and go we have three cones and rods or
whatever I don't know a whole lot about
it so I'm probably getting away wrong
for those that do but the general idea
is that I read something where it said
the cones are kind of like pushed
together so it decreases your ability to
differentiate but to between certain
wavelengths yeah maybe there's a
treatment that can be done via surgery
or something that'll that you know all
of a sudden boom there it is it
separates and then you with a
disadvantage work towards curing it for
everyone else people have done this
there have been a lot of stories of
people who were told because of this you
can't do that and then they went to
school to fix it and that's their
contribution but the reality is yeah men
you but you couldn't be in the NBA
either like whoa whoa I'm actually quite
good at basketball but but you can't be
in the NBA dude
well okay okay for the that's actually
bad example because you could say no no
honestly if I trained I I'm not saying
I'm NBA worthy but I feel pretty good
basketball like I like playing about
school I grew up in Chicago I was I was
like a teenager watching Michael Jordan
crush it in my town like we owned
basketball in the 90s it was awesome so
I think that basketball fan to be fair
the NBA is something you can dedicate
your entire life to to get fully built
to be in it regardless but let's say you
were born with one leg it's like what
are we gonna do are we gonna change the
rules and be like you gotta allow it no
there wouldn't work it's and that's what
a lot of these weird you know people on
the left think that's gonna happen
yeah they don't understand that we are
not created as perfect androids that are
built to spec to do anything we want
yeah they call it the blank slate theory
all humans are the same and they're
programmed it's not did you know that
humans raise their arms instinctively
when they when they succeed no I didn't
know that you're not again you know
people win something the goal yeah and
I'll throw their arms in the air yeah
they they they're they know this is
inherent human behavior that's not
taught because people who have never
blind people still do it Wow people
blind from birth like kids will do the
same thing now they've never seen it
they've never seen it but they'll do it
that's good so they're like like right
so they so they can track things that
are inherent to human behavior and it's
obvious man like how did how come all
the cats do the same things they're not
taught to be cats to scratch things and
there's a scratch in their DNA yeah it's
a it's I think I think look there's a
mix of environment and nature and
nurture is a mix of nature and nurture
yeah I think my understanding of a lot
of these studies which is not an expert
I'm not a biologist or evolutionary
psychologist is that the the variance in
nature can be easily overcome by nurture
meaning you can take any person and
nurture them to be successful but
genetics do play a role in everything
about us okay including intelligence and
a lot of people don't want to talk about
it because it's considered controversial
or you know whatever but Sam Sam Harris
so you familiar Sam Harris no with st.
Mary's a neuroscientist order yeah all I
know is that he's an eighth
I don't know what his specialty is he's
a very very famous podcaster okay he's
the expert and he had some conversation
where he very simply said if we know
that genetics play a role in our
development I think you did I want to
make sure I'm not miss courting him but
my understanding of his argument was
because he did it with like Ezra Klein
of Vox or something he said something
like if we know that genetics plays a
role in everything about how we're
developing why wouldn't it play a role
in our cognitive capabilities that
doesn't mean that there are certain
people who are too dumb to function it
just means that it plays a role it's not
you know if it shouldn't be
controversial and my under simple truth
my understanding of it is some people
are gonna be smarter some people are
gonna be stupider there there may it's
not necessarily about race it's about
you know how do you describe it it's
about certain clusters of you know
genetic happenstance that are either
smarter or not and sometimes it is in
one area and whatnot another area but
ultimately my understanding of it is
that it can be overcome by nature and I
think that's that's true I think people
can make choices and choose to be better
choose to be great choose to better
themselves and they can choose not to
it's about freewill you know okay but
yeah long story short the people that
are taken over these organizations the
people who want to abolish the police
there's no rhyme or reason to what
they're saying so we'll wrap up these
thoughts and jump over super chats when
it comes to abolishing the police that
should be evidence to everybody that
though I I'm sorry man we're done here
we're done every time I've said hey that
idea is stupid the Democrats are
adopting a dumb idea and people have
been like well I kind of understand what
they're saying with this one okay tell
me what they mean by this can you can
you can anybody I don't want to get rid
of the police that's I don't get it we
can entertain the conversation of
community policing and stuff but to
actually campaign and abolish the police
I laughed so hard when I heard they want
to disband the police in Minneapolis
it's ridiculous yeah so what do you do
you get you get mugged you're like I
guess I'll just die you're not gonna
call you know you're in your house and
someone's breaking in like well
how far they make it 34 years it's been
fun mostly - exactly yeah gun and that's
and that's the counter that that's
that's like okay you know what this
normally wouldn't work but we shouldn't
be relying on police for everything
anyway yeah we should be like come in my
house and like that was at Polk County
Sheriff yep I'll blow you out the door
and he's telling his residence that's
what I'm suggesting to them to blow you
out the door and itself it's crazy that
it's a scaling problem there's mass
shootings mm-hmm
because we've always had them you know I
guess per capita you can see differences
yeah but because we have so many people
and mass media dude when I went to Glenn
Beck studio last year he's got all these
really really old newspapers on the
studio walls in his building and one of
them I was reading a story from like
1850 or whatever and it was a story
about a guy at a bar a saloon and some
guy walked out smoking a cigarette
pulled out his flintlock pistol put it
in the chest of the guy and shot him for
no reason well I guess that's an
argument for you know I don't actually
don't know what year was it was really
was a long time ago it was a holy cow
lock pistol or some ridiculous nonsense
jeez and I don't know if maybe it wasn't
have one like this though I don't know
but it was like he shot him in the chest
and it was like these things have
happened the Wild West man you know we
watch movies about the guy walking in
and being like the sheriff can't stop me
I'll put a bullet anyone who stands in
my way you and they never have a
showdown
dude dueling used to be legal too you
know yeah yeah I don't I was thinking
about dueling I was thinking like maybe
it should be legal you know no we're not
two people mutual combat you know that
mutual combats legal in a lot of places
right really yeah like if you if you
tell someone take it outside and they
agree they don't arrest anybody oh wow
yeah it's mutual combat like you guys
agreed to fight not every jurisdiction
has this but some states are like
seriously but what are they gonna do if
two people are like don't you do this
I'm gonna I'll hit you in Psych oh yeah
buddy you can't do it I'll see you
outside they go outside together two
grown adults two grown Kentucky adults
went outside and punched each other
would you arrest both of them well some
places probably would but I don't know
man I don't know if it's
it's a Liberty it's a libertarian
concept challenge of dueling if two
grown consenting adults say I want a
duel to the death it's like there need
to be like dueling pits so that they
don't bullet stray bullets don't go
fly-in killing random innocent do a
little arenas yeah yeah that's great I
mean that's gonna be like a new sport do
you managed to do that
like it seemed like life was so what's
the opposite of precious I don't know
people were very cavalier about their
wives
yeah they're like well I'm gonna die
anyway I might as well have a duel now
at the age of 19 yeah I won't die when
I'm 35 of some kind of illness yeah that
still is a kid that's the family the
Family Guy joke where it's like they did
a flashback episode where was like the
1700s or something in Peter like stubbed
his toe and like got a supply slight cut
and goes well I have a small cut I'm
gonna dive the infection so like that's
it and I had a good run yeah he's like
well I'm 19 years old and I've got an
infection now I'm gonna die that used to
be yeah that's crazy it's not like that
anymore no it is not we are in a time of
like we're we're all I don't know we
don't think about it you know I do have
I'd be willing to bet if you went back
in time and grabbed mister you know
George Washington and brought him back
here and you were like did you know that
dueling is illegal he's like what why
yeah you know and and and he's like big
they owned people back then yeah like
there's a lot of things we got rid of
that would shock them that we can't do
today so for so so for the better I
don't think about dueling though is
consenting adults like shouldn't
consenting adults be allowed to do what
they want with each other yeah yeah
is your body yours it's a crazy you know
Trump signed the right to try bill
eunetta's you could try medicine that's
not approved yet
yeah if you're dying if you're yeah if
you're dying you have no other choice
why was that illegal in the first place
yeah that's a legit if I was dying of
some weird rare disease and they're like
well we have this experimental drug that
has worked but it's not approved yet
it's like I thought it hit me with it if
I wasn't if I was dying
uh-huh and they were like we're gonna
try this therapy and it failed we're
gonna try this next extreme therapy it
failed well we got this experiment
experimental fare therapy and it failed
I'd be like what haven't we tried all
right okay well tell you what I'm gonna
do
20 minutes give me the bleach yeah okay
literally anything
yeah there's zero point one one zero
point zero zero zero zero one percent
chance of saving my life
yeah whatever it helps someone else to
yeah so Trump talked about you know is
there a way we can you know put some
would he say disinfectant under this
some kind of disinfectant under skin
people Fran and it everyone went nuts
and got angry at them and I think it was
a silly comment but it is they do have
treatments where they take UV lights and
put it down into your into your lungs
and stuff yeah weird and h2o2
hydroperoxide you could argue is a
disinfectant under the skin
but the point I'm making is if I had
some kind of like contagion and
everything failed rote you're not gonna
stop me from trying something if you're
like you're gonna die right now there's
nothing you can do about it we have no
treatment so I'll be like all right
what's right I don't know bleach kills
these things yeah you have any ideas doc
you know a beginning Pig try it on me
I'll take whatever you got crystals I'll
take those manic the healing crystal
bring in the crystal lady haven't rub
crystals in acupuncture we'll just go
for it I'm gonna die sound therapy
sounds whatever man any vibration yes
yep drop me from bring me into a zero-g
a plane free-falling with acupuncture
crystals no suction cup lamps all over
my body all at the same time and I'll be
on Keith I'll be in a ketogenic diet
while I'm doing it a vegan ketogenic
diet just do everything yeah but no but
it's crazy that we have laws saying like
you can't do that with your own body
yeah I don't get that my body well hey
man Trump sign that bill it's a good
thing yep thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you